now a victim of the serial rapist David
Carrick has told Sky News he used his
job as a Firearms officer to gain her
trust before subjecting her to months of
physical and mental abuse telling her
the safest place you can be is with me
now Carrick was formally discharged from
the metropolitan police earlier today
and Sky News has obtained footage filmed
by Carrick as he walked around his home
in watch in which he attacked many of
his victims we can bring in our crime
correspondent Martin brunt for more on
this
hello to you Martin
um tell us what we're about to see
like all media organizations we've been
very keen to try to talk
to any of David carrick's victims you
can imagine that most of them are
reluctant too but today one woman who's
now in her 40s was happy to talk to my
colleague Andy Hughes she lives outside
London she cannot be identified because
she's a victim of sexual attacks but she
gave a chilling insight into her life
living with David Carrick and she also
shared with us a video that he shot
around the house where he committed a
lot of his crimes
so here we have the bathroom
come out to the hallway we've got the
heating for the bathroom floor
into a minor bedroom
hey
[Applause]
clutter everywhere as usual
side
the view from our window
[Laughter]
[Applause]
up to the corridor
we've got cupboard space outside here
office
round into trim
again clutter everywhere
upstairs
[Applause]
foreign
and the front room finally
again back up to the back arm
that video part of that video shows the
small cupboard where
Carrick locked some of his victims some
of them according to police for up to 10
hours
now the woman who shared that video with
us uh spoke about her life with David
Carrick she couldn't do it on camera but
I'll give you a flavor of some of the
things she said to our colleague Andy
Hughes she said he boasted about his job
at the Met he told me the safest place I
can be was with him at first he was the
dream man he was so Charming but over
time that changed
she then went on to talk about that
change he was so evil she said I have no
idea how someone so messed up can be a
police officer
never mind give him a gun if it shot
someone I wouldn't have been surprised
and then she said
when I started to speak to his friends
he would stop me he didn't want me
talking to anyone a couple of his
colleagues reached out to me after that
a couple have been in touch since his
arrest as well so she's clearly saying
that she did meet some of carrick's
carrick's colleagues from the Met police
and suggested that they knew something
of what was going on they certainly told
her that they were concerned about her